welcome to part one of our 56p part
series can we please never stop talking
about Taylor Swift where each panelist
picks a news story and links it back to
Taylor Swift Tyrus you go first i' just
like to say up until this point I'm
being forced against my will ladies and
gentlemen you noticed in the highlights
there was never once me mentioning that
the name I shall never
speak but apparently I don't get paid
unless I do this so all right so uh
Toyota issues a do not drive advisory
50,000 car owners over potentially
deadly airbag issues because the car
will not operate unless you download
Taylor Swift's latest album so the only
way you can drive safely is if by you
downloading downloading a Taylor Swift
album